the scarlet king is a really bad guy
he's a giant interdimensional nightmare
god
intent on breaching our reality and
wrecking terrible havoc on everything
we know and love he's been responsible
for untold suffering and chaos across
countless worlds
timelines and layers of reality to many
he's even somewhat of a final boss
to the scp foundation and just when you
think he couldn't get any worse
it turns out that he's also a deadbeat
dad not only did the scarlet king once
have a cult literally named the children
of the scarlet king
before it was destroyed by dr montauk
and the scp foundation
he also had at least seven actual
children
each one is speculated to be a powerful
anomaly but it's tough to find concrete
answers as to who
or what exactly most of them are so
today we're putting on our researcher
hats
and digging deep into the foundation's
lore to present
our theories on the potential progeny of
the scp foundation's greatest
enemy and if nothing else we may finally
be able to get this dark lord of all
evil to start paying all the child
support he probably owes by now
first if you're not well versed in
scarlet king vore you may be wondering
how exactly does an evil chaos god have
kids
is there a scarlet queen out there who
prefers to stay out of the limelight
the answer isn't quite that simple and
it has everything to do with scp-231
and big red's most devoted cult the
non-biological children
of the scarlet king they kidnapped a
group of seven girls
and performed a number of dark rituals
that resulted in them becoming vessels
for the scarlet king
seven terrible kids these seven girls
have become known as
scp-231 anyone who accesses those files
and trust us they aren't a pretty sight
we'll find that the containment
procedures mostly involve performing the
infamous montauk procedure on the
surviving girls to keep them from giving
birth six of the seven brides have given
birth to nightmares beyond comprehension
and are now
dead with only one still remaining
successfully contained
but here at the scp foundation you need
to learn to comprehend the
incomprehensible according to a
classified document
scp-231 may technically be a neutralized
anomaly without us
even knowing and incidentally this gives
us our most certain
answer on the children of the scarlet
king on this one
the apple fell very very far from the
tree
according to the secret document scp-999
that's right the adorable tickle monster
is the seventh child of the scarlet king
he must be so disappointed that
everyone's favorite little blob didn't
want to join the family business of
absolute evil
for anyone who doesn't know scp-999 is a
slimy yellow entity
that only seems capable of absolute
compassion it brings joy to everyone
in its presence and with prolonged
exposure it can even cure disorders like
ptsd
anxiety and depression he's so good at
this
that he even cured scp-231-a
his de facto mother of her trauma and
allowed her to return happily to her
family after some amnestic treatment
the scarlet king has another good reason
to be ashamed of his cheerful blobby's
son
ancient diabetes prophecy dictates that
scp-999 may someday become
so powerful that his force of absolute
love and good
overwhelms the scarlet king's evil and
chaos
think of him as the luke skywalker to
the scarlet king's darth vader
though we probably can't expect a cool
lightsaber battle between them any time
soon
how disappointing so if scp-999 is the
quiet sensitive black sheep of the
scarlet family
who's the golden child who makes his
evil father proud
the real chimp off the old block that
would be our dear reptilian friend
scp-682 the malicious lizard heavily
implied to be a child of the scarlet
king
if you know literally anything about 682
your reaction to finding out that he's
the spawn of cruelty personified is
probably
yeah that makes sense just as scp-999 is
the scarlet king's innocent
optimistic young child 682 is kind of
like his edgy teenager
still in the middle of a misanthropic
phase he shows no sign of leaving any
time
soon the fact that 682 appears to find
anything about the world around him
utterly disgusting
seems to be a trait he inherited from
his dear old dad
and the fact he seems pretty much
impossible to kill also lends credence
to the popular theory he's got nightmare
god blood running through
his veins 682 has also started
displaying a particular hatred for 999
ever since an incident
where 999 tickled them into submission
so family dinners are probably
extra awkward for these two 999 and 682
are the most certain children but that
still leaves us with five more children
to identify
it's worth remembering that the waters
are murkier from here on in
but we've searched far and wide through
the foundation archives to find
possible answers if your interpretation
differs
remember that it's just a theory an scp
explained theory thankfully we do have
some assistance here
the tail dust and blood hinted at what
each of the seven children of the
scarlet king represents
and that may help us narrow down our
choices here to put things into
perspective
it's believed that 682 was the fourth
child to be born
representing wrath and 999 was the
seventh
representing hope according to this tale
the first of the seven children
represents dominion and as a result
is skilled in the ways of war and has
the power to lead the king's forces to
victory
according to one foundation theorist
this child could potentially be
scp-239 also known as the witch child
this entity is so powerful that as part
of its normal containment procedures
it's eternally kept in a coma why
because this seemingly normal child has
dominion over reality
and can change it to her whims her
thoughts are so powerful that just her
brainwaves can damage physical matter
and she can make things disappear or
manifest in an
instant she's also impossible to kill
with skin that's almost totally
impenetrable
much like scp-682 she's also
frighteningly strong in both the offense
and defense department
we're talking about such a powerful
telepath that dr
clef has campaigned for her immediate
termination
just because it's safer that way this is
certainly a frightening wonderkin that
the scarlet king would be
proud to call his daughter next the
second child
according to the prophecy this child
represents longing
the child has the power to bring forth
armies which will help the scarlet king
in his conquest
for this we actually have a pretty
unconventional theory
scp-029 also known as the daughter of
darkness
if the name alone wasn't enough to
suggest that she's got an extremely
sinister father
she also fits the profile of being very
aggressive and
incredibly hard to kill but even more
damning is her connections to the
symbology of longing
one of her most dangerous powers is
causing men to fall into almost
trance-like devotion to her after
spending time around her they're
suddenly willing to
murder in her honor strangling their
victims in hopes of raising kali
the hindu god of destruction whom has
many similarities to the scarlet king
she certainly fits the bill of someone
capable of raising armies in the dark
lord's name
one strike against our scarlet king
connection theory is that the file
states the daughter of darkness was
first discovered
in india which wouldn't match up with
the other information we know to be
fact however while this is a long shot
given the sensitive nature of everything
involving the scarlet king it's
extremely possible that false
information was supplied to bury the
connection
considering the cover-ups and lies
involving anomalies like scp-1000
this certainly isn't an unprecedented
move on the part of the foundation
next the third child this child is
associated with all things desolation
implying destruction fire ashes
pestilence and death
across the battlefield when it comes to
spreading destruction and death on a
mass scale
one particular scp comes to mind scp-058
the heart of darkness this creature has
scarlet king written
all over it it's evil it's mysterious
it's pretty much impossible to kill and
it causes mass casualties every time it
escapes its containment chamber
it causes fires whips people to death
with its razor-sharp tendrils
and sprays highly corrosive acid from
its scorpion-like
tail and it's even red given that we
know for a fact this entity suddenly
emerged out of
something that's now been expunged from
the records in an undisclosed site
it's extremely possible that the entity
058 came from was scp-231-3
this is a child that the scarlet king
would definitely be proud of
given that it's impossible to reason
with and feel solely motivated by
causing destruction
misery and chaos we can't think of an
entity that better suits the desolation
moniker
than scp-058 next skipping past
scp-682 at number four the fifth child
of the scarlet king is associated with
the loose concept
of lack the prophecy then goes into more
detail
saying that this child is powerful in
the ways of magic and is able to use
their abilities to cause
great destruction here we have another
unconventional proposal
what if child number five wasn't
actually a child
but children that's because we think
this description perfectly fits
scp-1765 the nightmarish reality warping
sisters who we think may actually be
triplets
of the scarlet king's fifth bride now
hear us out
these are actually some of the most
powerful enemies the foundation has ever
attempted to contain
and we know nothing about their past
before being bound to a few
objects by the serpent's hand these
sadistic reality warpers are so
devastatingly powerful
that the only action the foundation can
take against them is letting them have
free reign over the containment site
they currently inhabit
all the foundation can do is hope they
never get bored of tormenting the people
inside
as we all know the scarlet king despises
science
progress and order so perhaps a perfect
punishment for the foundation
in his many eyes is giving them a taste
of their own
medicine the sisters though particularly
their ringleader
are a perverse shadow of the
foundation's love of the scientific
method
they take these methods and use them for
an activity that the scarlet king finds
much more enjoyable tormenting and
killing people whenever these crafty
triplets set their mind to it
their horrifically powerful magic is
able to cause massive devastation
just like the prophecy for the fifth
bride's offspring dictates
and finally the sixth child of the
scarlet king
the concept associated with this one is
hidden
meaning it can change its face and walk
unnoticed through
creation it's also said to have the
responsibility of opening the ways
between worlds
and allowing the war to end all wars to
first begin
there have been a huge number of guesses
for this spot with some even suggesting
scp-055 the anti-meme but since we're
having fun here
we also want to make an even wilder
suggestion
we posit that the sixth child of the
scarlet king is
alison chao also known as ls and the
black queen
the most powerful member of the
serpent's hand
we get it we have a lot of explaining to
do but hear us out
alison chow was a member of the
serpent's hand or
technically many members multiple
versions of her exist
across parallel dimensions in the scp
multiverse
they're mostly all estranged daughters
of foundation researcher dr
charles gears this estrangement leads
them to collaborate in the wanderers
library
the secret base of the serpent's hand to
conduct raids on the foundation in
revenge but what if the leader of these
alternate allisons had an ulterior
motive
because in the infinite number of
possibilities offered by the multiverse
this one was not the daughter of charles
gears but the scarlet king
she's merely using the pain of her
counterparts to manipulate them into
accomplishing her true father's goal
undermining the scp foundation let's
break it down
the hidden child is prophesied to walk
unnoticed through creation
not only does alison chow appear human
the use of scp-268
a news boycott that causes the wearer to
become unnoticed
allows her to walk anywhere through
creation without being detected
but most importantly of all the hidden
child is said to be the one who opens
the way for the scarlet king's entrance
into our dimension and alison chao has
access to the wanderers library
an unfettered access point between
dimensions
if one of the infinite alisons was the
secret daughter of the scarlet king
would the wanderer's library not be a
perfect way for him to leave his own
dimension
and enter ours she could be the final
piece he needs
hidden under the nose of the foundation
and the serpent's hand
making all the secret power plays to
allow for the scarlet king's eventual
bloody revenge on our world
unless of course scp-999
the family disappointment stops him
first
we realize that some of these theories
may seem surprising
but when it comes to the anomalous
especially the scarlet king
the only thing you can ever expect is
the unexpected
do you agree with our theories if not
who do you think are the children of the
scarlet king
let us know down in the comments one
thing is for certain
we hope we never meet any of the
terrible tyrant's nasty children
except the tickle monster of course he
can hang with us anytime
now check out scp-001 the scarlet king
and scp-999 the tickle monster for more
information about the scarlet king
and his misfit children i'm dr vox
and i'll see you next time